60 years ago today civil rights leader
Medgar Evers was gunned down in front of
his Mississippi home just a few feet
away from his wife and three young
children Evers helped lead the fight to
register black voters and boycott whites
only businesses in the deeply segregated
state after he was killed his wife merly
Evers carried the Baton for racial
equality she says she wanted to honor
his legacy in an exclusive interview we
met Mrs Evers at the family's former
home in Jackson Mississippi
as we sit here in your house
what Memories does it bring back for you
what was it like living here
I see Love in This House
I'd
fear
[Music]
true
merly Evers has been fighting against
hatred all of her life perhaps in its
strongest form in the early 1960s when
her family was under constant threat
because of her husband Medgar Evers work
in the Civil Rights Movement I've had a
number of threatening calls people
calling me saying that they were going
to kill me saying if they're going to
blow my home up
and uh saying that I only had a few
hours to live how were you able to live
like that knowing that at any day could
be his last day
knowing that every day might be the last
day was the force behind
the deep love that America and I had for
each other
and our children did you ever question
if he loved the movement more than the
family did you ever ask him that
or was that not a fair question but I
did oh
What About Us
you have me
your wife who loves you dearly
you have these three children
and Medgar would tell me that's why I'm
doing what I'm doing
he told me at one time either you or
with me are you art
you make that decision and in the end
you decided my decision is I'm going to
stay with you
my decision was
excuse my grammar
ain't gonna leave that man
Medgar and Merle met when they were both
attending Alcorn a m College in 1950
they got married in 1951 and three years
later they moved to Jackson Mississippi
where Medgar would become the state's
first NAACP field secretary it was that
position that ultimately made him a
Target Medgar Evers 37 years old killed
from Ambush on Wednesday June 12
1963. a single bullet ended his life
there was the love of my life
and my children's father
I recall vividly
our children saying crying screaming
Daddy get up get up Daddy get up
and of course there were my screams and
trying to help him and remembering that
America and I had talked about
that scene
so many times
during that time you seem to be so
gracious is that
what you were really feeling at the time
what a beautiful front that was
because beneath it
was just determination to make them pay
but here is your husband preaching
against hatred did you find yourself
feeling hatred Yourself In This Moment
as negative as it is
that's what kept me going
who was your hatred directed to you know
or at I would have to say it was
initially directed to everyone
whose skin color
was not the same as mine
might be ugly but that's the way I felt
I was determined
to see whomever was responsible for
my husband's death would pay
that
ugly
period of hating
actually saved me
it saved me in the sense that I could
retreat in my room or my bed someplace
and plan
destruction
that seemed to relieved me of
suicide really you thought about taking
your own life
and leaving your children but I couldn't
because of my children
then what would they do merley and
medgar's children were nine eight and
three years old when their father was
killed we asked their daughter Rina to
join us in their old dining room to
watch an interview that her mother gave
to CBS News just one day after she lost
her husband I would hate to think
that the sacrifice that he made while he
was living
and I also by his death would go in vain
I hope that by his death
that this will help all of us
not only in Jackson
in Mississippi
are in the United States
but throughout the world
wow I know
I've never seen you've never seen that
what do you think when you see that
video of yourself
and you see that young woman at 30.
I had difficulty watching them did you
yes
um
because because
I see something in that woman
that I didn't realize was there
which was
a strength
also see determination
just by the eloquence of your words
and by the poignancy to address the
world in not just Mississippi
and to hear these words
come back again today you use the phrase
a lot that is that is life that he
didn't die in vain that was very
important to you
very important to this day
it's important
in the year that followed Medgar Evers
murder Mrs Evers would sit through two
trials for the man who shot him both of
those trials ended in hung juries the
jurors were all white men
but in 1994 a third trial with new
evidence and witness testimony would
look and end differently when he was
found guilty what did that guilty
verdict mean to you
it meant that I was free
all I want to do
is say yay
free at last
amid the fight for justice for Medgar
merley took up his fight for equality of
course I loved him
I did not want him forgotten
that was my first motivation the second
was to bring positive change if I
possibly could she was also building a
life with her children in California you
went back to school you ran for congress
what were you looking for back then what
did you want
honestly
Vengeance vengeance
by doing well
by achieving
Mrs Evers took on leadership roles in
Corporate America she was the first
black woman to be named commissioner of
the board of the Los Angeles Department
of Public Works and she married again it
was her second husband Walter Williams
who back in 1995 encouraged her to run
for chairperson of the NAACP
almost everyone told me you won't win
the men won't allow it
[Music]
when I remember having a big smile on my
face
control I need
then you take the attitude of watching
me yeah that's right watch me Williams
who had been battling cancer died days
after she won by a single vote
over the next few years she restored the
embattled group status as a leading
civil rights organization in the country
and its Financial standing being black
and female didn't seem to deter you Ms
Zephyrs and anything that no no no it
didn't it motivated me
tell me that I can't do something
I'll kill myself trying to do that
this past week the Evers were honored
with special events in Jackson including
a celebration from early Evers and a
Gala marking 60 years since the world
lost her husband
and I ask you to please
always
keep Medgar Evers memory
in your minds
and in your hearts
is there anything else you would like to
accomplish either personally or
professionally
hmm
well that's a good question
almost selfish node
I would be thankful for good health
and memory yes yes yes
I hope I never
lose the will to fight for what I
believe in
she says that she sees things today that
she still wants to fight but guys I
walked out of that house number one
wishing they would adopt me I was in
such awe of her she's so eloquent she's
so solid she's still so compassionate
and still feels so
um
firm in her beliefs and what she wants
for this country and the people in this
country I walked out of there I I can't
even explain how proud I felt number
when she's 90 years old and to admit
that yes she had hatred you know because
that's not something people say of
course to admit that she had that and
that she had to work through it which
she had certainly done well done by you
and our CBS team but just a credit to
her for her honesty exactly
thoughtfulness before she responded to
every single question yeah um very
thoughtful very thoughtful but Vengeance
when that is a motivating factor for
someone that usually ends in pain for
everybody involved Vengeance by doing
well by doing well and achieving Nate
there are still bullet holes in the wall
she was telling me when they were
younger the kids they used to have
rehearsals if their gunshots drop to the
floor run and get in the bathtub which
they did that night kids old enough to
know what was happening yes on the one
hand not understand it but also to know
your father